we're kind of in a stage where we can
plan
much longer term than we did before
and there's so much opportunities coming
out of covid um
especially in physical retail as well as
like international and like online and
everything so
you know now is a really exciting time
for me
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with louimi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford let's talk about
jewelry and retail experience before
covet after covet during kovid
i'm honored to be here with koni nam
founder of astrid and meu
connie started astrid and mu nine years
ago wanting to create a jewelry brand
that brings out the sentiment she felt
when traveling around the world
visiting local boutiques and markets
they are aiming to change the jewelry
experience through unique physical
experience
strong community and innovative products
prior to this
coney was trained as an investment
banker in asia working mainly on tech
ipos
she has an mba from london business
school connie nam thank you for joining
me
how are you today yeah i'm good thank
you so much for having me
your your beautiful daughter summers is
there and next year so maybe maybe
she'll make an appearance but but
what i love about this show is the
informality of it and getting to pick
a leaders brains in the most natural
environment because really what i want
to hear is is your personal
journey i haven't had many people from
the jewelry business i had a chance to
check out
you know the website and this and you
know i i can't wait to hear about the
experiential part of the stores
uh so connie we don't have much time of
course talk to me a little bit about
your
yeah how do you get started in jewelry
yeah so i mean i come from an investment
banking background like boring
but you know i like typically like as a
typical banker i was burnt out and then
i did my mba at london business school
and while i was
at london business school i just had a
vague idea of wanting to be in fashion
so i worked for lvmh like on a very
short stint
and i decided that you know corporate
life is not for me
um so i wanted to start something
like i always wanted to start my own
business i didn't know when but i
just took the plunge and started it as a
project and when i was starting the
project
um i didn't really know which category i
mean i always loved jewelry but i also
love fashion but when i looked at
different spaces i just felt like
jewelry
lacked that innovation piece and also
you know i grew up with jewelry my mom
is a jewelry obsessed she's like a
magpie
and my dad used to travel a lot for
business and
you know everything like every single
piece of jewelry had some kind of
meaning because we'd always pick
something up from travels and
i used to love going to the markets and
pick up jewelry they weren't expensive
jewelry but they all
had meaning but you know when i was
going to the so so in the uk we call it
high street high street means i guess
like shopping streets
if we go to the um shopping streets and
go to big brand names um you know
everything's a bit stale
and you know very formal even even the
affordable
jewelry brands like swarovski and
pandora
they they don't need to be but
everything's under the glass people are
in uniforms
very very formal and you need to you
know ask like bug the sales assistants
to
take things out for you which could be
quite um intimidating and
especially for a shopper like me i
normally know exactly what i want and i
just want to be left alone
so um i just felt like there was that
piece missing in the services bit but
also
within the products there was so much
innovation going on in fashion
um and so much like aspiration and
selling that dream and that
none of that existed in jewelry it was
very much um
i i guess like a bit of a stale industry
where it was dominated by
and you know yeah it was complaining the
stillness
how do i explain this how do you explain
the staleness yeah
how do i explain the staleness i think
it just like
you know if you just look at the imagery
or campaigns that
um jewelry brands take out it's just
like
models looking very cold like it's just
um
the top top of the head and you know
they normally don't have
anything on like they're normally like
skinny white models
and i just felt like they don't portray
that personality
so that's one example and another
example is like
as i mentioned the services if you
walked into the stores everyone was in
uni
uniform so there was no personality
coming through so
i wanted to create a jewelry brand that
has personality
in terms of physical experience but also
the image that we portray but also
with the designs that are accessible and
commercial
and um exciting and a brand that's a bit
more sexy than the traditional
jewelry brand so i wanted a jewelry
brand that acts like a fashion brand
and that's how i started astrid mew i i
guess it was again
that was quite lengthy no i i
i love it when when you know people
share with me how you know coming from
investment banking
and you know you're talking about
stillness and formality i can't imagine
a a position you know you're also an
associate at hsbs
and you know you're i can't imagine you
know
you know coming into a different
industry disrupting it from within
but why why traditionally do we have
this mentality when regards to jewelry i
imagine it's because
these are really expensive items and so
you know you need somebody to help you
handle them but what you're saying is
that you're actually thinking of an of a
different model
which makes things you know
psychologically more accessible
right yeah yeah i think you're
absolutely right and i think
historically
the women were not the consumers of the
jewelry so women were wearing them but
they were gifted by men
so i think a lot of the experiences were
tailored to men
buying gifts so maybe they needed like a
lot of guidance because they
you know they're not the actual end user
or and
a lot of the jewelry shops or brand
owners are men
as well so i wanted to create this um
jewelry because we
we are the end users we i wanted to
create a jewelry brand that's
by women for women um women buying for
themselves or women buy for their
girlfriends
and um i think that's why the experience
was very different
versus like what i'm creating so
i i saw that the stores are reopening on
april 12th
in inland tell me you know if i walk
into a store
you know it doesn't matter if i'm a man
woman whatever what do i experience
because a lot of times i i read
you know you're a lot of thinking a lot
about the experiential retail
and and i get excited about that a lot
so what what do i experience
as as a customer as i walk into this
yeah yeah i mean firstly a lot of
personality we don't have
uniform code or we don't have you know
obviously like we want everyone to be
presentable
and on brand but everyone can bring
their personality
out like in terms of what they're aware
but also like you know just be natural
and be yourself
and speak to customers like you would
talk to a friend so you don't feel like
you're walking into the a jewelry store
so a lot of our customers
actually are locals to the stores that
we're in
so i mean like we we are at scale
relatively but everyone feels like it's
a local store
so they're coming in to catch up with
their friend um who are store managers
and store associates so that's one
part of experience but another part is
we have a couple of services
you know we sell jewelry but we also
provide services that are piercing
we also have fine line tattoo services
we also have bracelet
welding services meaning i think a lot
of people get confused with this that
we have a chain of um gold like
thread and we have um professional
jewelers with the welding machine
welding the bracelet right onto your
wrist so it's like a forever bracelet
that's tied so you don't have that class
paying
that annoys you so we have that service
um
yeah and we have like private
consultation services so
all of these combined is that retail
experience that we have and
as the founder and leader of this
initiative how do you how do you create
a culture
where you know at one on one end you're
saying we're scaling on the other end
you're saying we still remain the local
brand that people
love and you know connect with on a
personal level you're mentioning that
people are connecting with the store
managers and the people working there
in an informal setting how do you how do
you cultivate a culture like that
because because it sounds like it's it's
not a terrible thing to do
yeah yeah it's it's a very very good
question because
when we're at a small scale it's so easy
because i can just like go
like you know go into the store and talk
about it like and just randomly walk in
and talk to the store managers but
obviously like i can't do that now
um because um i mean like not to sound
that i'm busy but like i have
you know like a lot of team to manage
and like
strategic directions that i need to
manage and things like that so it's
about like
um you know defining the value
sets that i want to create defining the
culture so what we did last year was
we redefined our values into three key
components so
that involved everyone in the business
so we had small workshops in groups of
five and everyone had to bring
you know a piece of example of when they
felt
at their best at astrid and you and then
we distilled those down to three
different values
and everything so the first is grow
together second is celebrate each other
third is break boundaries and everything
every single behavior
sits under that so that people can bring
we can bring
those behaviors out based on values but
we also it's also about hiring the right
people
so hiring the right people that are
willing to you know
that that get excited about this journey
and that get excited about making
friends
not just about selling and like pushing
through profits
yeah so it's like hiring like absolutely
the right people but also
you know having all those structures um
the recruitment process that everyone
can follow recruitment process
and also like the appraisal process that
strictly follows
these values not just their business
kpis
so i think all of these combined are
really important in culminating that
culture
so if i'm not mistaken it's been about
eight or nine years right in the making
and what what has been you know if you
look back
um coming fresh into the retail space
from investment banking
were there any like crazy surprises that
you're saying like wow like i did not
expect
this to happen or some major challenges
that you've seen along the way
that if you were to go back eight years
you would tell sort of younger connie
about
you know how to advance with this with
this company
um i guess like um if i were to go back
i guess this is a difficult question
right because um
it's a balance i think i did what i did
because i was young and naive and if i
knew everything it would be very
daunting to start anything because i
know how
how much work it takes but i i guess
going big
yeah yeah i think um i mean i don't know
like whether i could have done it better
if i knew everything
but to be honest but i think one thing
um
i might do differently if i were to
start another company
is i would probably hire a very strong
team
earlier on so yeah i had a lot of like
initially i i made a lot of hiring
mistakes and
i realized um along the way like having
a great team
i'm not just individually but the team
that fits into the values and the fit
team that can gel into the existing team
like building that strong team is so
important so i would really focus on
that initially
and that was not not my natural go-to
initially especially coming from
investment banking it was all about
like looking at the metrics like looking
at how the business was going not
about the people but i would definitely
focus a lot more on the people
no and it sounds to me like you know
what what you said before about this
idea that if you
how do you known you know some of the
difficulties of what's gonna what's in
store for you you might not have even
gone on on some of the journeys which i
think is you know that's a really
interesting way of looking at it that if
you have
that if you don't have that you know
that naivety then you're not really able
to move on
you're not able to push forward
sometimes
yeah absolutely and i could pour
everything in because it was um
you know my first baby and i didn't know
anything and part of it was my learning
journey as well
right what are some of the most exciting
moments you know whether it's like you
know
the launch of the first store or the
scaling of the second store
if you look back at the past eight years
what were some of the really you know
the aha moments that you had
i think um getting our store model right
was really exciting
because initially we were just selling
jewelry and obviously we had that
service component
a customer services component that was
very exciting that everyone loved but
you know the business really kicked off
once we started offering these
additional
services like piercing tattoos and
welding
so getting that business model right was
really exciting for me because it also
meant
that our stores were becoming cash cows
whereas before the online business was
kind of funding this store so we could
really scale that
um and and then like i'm really excited
about
right now actually although we're stuck
like you know in the lockdown but just
the prospect of
being able to expand our stores but also
we're planning international growth and
we're kind of in a stage where we can
plan much
longer term than we did before and
there's so much opportunities coming out
of covid
um especially in physical retail as well
as like international and like online
and everything so
you know now is a really exciting time
for me
right so take me back to that moment
where you know london shuts down
and you realize okay for the foreseeable
future it could be weeks it could be
months so we're not going to have this
experiential retail you have
a lot of staff that is now not coming to
the stores
we were talking about you know this
personal connection you have and all of
a sudden that personal connection
doesn't really work
right how do how do you think through
that as a leader
oh wow when when the pandemic first did
like
i couldn't really think i just had to
put together action plan and fire fights
and i think that was the case for all
leaders so
i mean the first thing like was oh my
god like what's going to happen to the
staff like how are we going to pay them
so
the first thing was i went to the van i
went to our head of finance and we ran a
model like okay like if we
assume zero revenue for the next six
months like
you know how like zero revenue how long
can we last
um yeah and i think her answer was like
12 months and i was like
okay like let's pay 50 um
to all our staff until like you know six
months on so this is before like the
government
came up with furlough scheme or anything
because i knew that i had to
they probably had to survive like on the
salary
but we probably couldn't pay fully um so
that's the first thing i did and
you know the government announcement
obviously after a couple of weeks was a
total relief because we knew that we
could save save that much on cash and
then the next thing we did was um
you know like we cut down all the
marketing
on budget but really communicated to our
customers
online on a very personal level so we
weren't talking about jewelry we were
just talking about like how are you
like how are you taking care of yourself
and then the next thing when everything
settled down was we introduced a virtual
styling session so our store manager is
actually
you know like customers can book an
appointment and our store managers would
show jewelry to them so that they can
style themselves etc because they didn't
the customers at the end of the day
didn't want to hear too much about
work from home or self-care anymore
because everyone was doing it
they actually wanted to you know see
jewelry and
you know forget about like what's going
on they wanted us to sell that dream
so we started doing that through online
styling
amazing and so actually this episode is
going to air on april 13th and i believe
april 12th
is going to be the first time that the
stores are reopening
yeah yes hopefully fingers crossed so
congratulations hopefully are you ready
for some fun questions we just have a
few minutes left and i know you have to
go
all right so number one what is your
favorite subject in school
oh my favorite subject my favorite
subject um
i mean it's quite odd but it's a
combination of i i loved art
um and anything creative but i like all
the art classes
like art fine art photography but i also
loved math
um yeah because like if i knew a couple
of formula and logic i could solve
everything and
i'm i'm quite a lazy person i don't like
memorizing and things so i thought like
math was quite easy for me
i loved it very different
subjects amazing one of your role models
in life a real or fake
um role models i mean i i love oprah
winfrey
i love how she can bring out that
vulnerability
out in other people and she's so good at
reading people
and that's a that's one of my goals in
life to be able to read through people
so like
yeah she's my role model and she's just
like an amazing business person as well
amazing and the last question three
words you would use to describe yourself
um i would say like i mean i don't want
to admit this but like competitive
because this is what like everyone tells
me i'm one of those like really
competitive people like when it comes to
petty games
so competitive um visionary
and i guess like creative those are the
three things
i love it connie thank you so so much
for coming here i know how busy you are
and i really appreciate it best of luck
with everything that you have in store
i really appreciate you taking the time
this was wonderful and and
again hopefully congratulations on
yesterday's launch so
take stay safe and stay healthy and i
can't wait to come and experience the
stores myself thank you
yeah thank you for having me please come